[Music]
there are only about a hundred and fifty
speakers of the Ocracoke brogue now and
they all live on one end of this barrier
island on the coast of North Carolina
which is basically an enlarged sandbar
within the next 50 years the brogue will
disappear wait you're gonna shine so
we're laughing our water far tonight
moonshine oh fish
the dialect on this island is sometimes
referred to as boy toy ters which is
their pronunciation of high tide Toit on
a science our high tide on this I saw in
the United States the Ocracoke broke is
probably the only dialect that is not
identified as being from America I do we
have a lot of people that think I'm from
Australia or Ireland yeah you look at
his boat CeCe's crabs
you know the first people came here from
England and Ireland Scotland just a nice
lady
I'm from Ocracoke I am the 10th
generation in my family from Ocracoke
that goes back to the mid 16 hundreds
the reason this dialect was perpetuated
for a couple of centuries was because
the people were very isolated they
didn't have much contact with with
people from the mainland
Ocracoke is an island that has always
lived around the water daddy
many of the unique items particularly
the vocabulary items are built around
the water and the sand and the weather
we have blowing really hard uses blow is
blowing hard a pop car died down you
know so you take hit a ride around the
island you take that loose
when we come out here and we is blowing
really hard and we take a big I take a
bad beating then you could say we'd be
mama you also find here lots of terms
for outsiders y'all are doing batter
this my wife is not from Maryland
we've been married 43 years she's still
a dig matter it's not a bad thing okay
it was basically the ding batter's who
change the dialect because so many
people came in even today there are more
Islanders who live here than online Durr
now it's changing within time we're all
going to lose it you know because of so
many people came in here it's a part of
Harwich that I'm proud of
some people think we talk funny I think
that's the way we talk okay it ain't
fair enough but get matter I mean oh
that's fine you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Tony peacock Robbie Goodman
my name is Sheila fry
I am a ten-time six-time two-time champ
of the national Hollerin contest so
Spivey's corner North Carolina Hollerin
is a controlled sound that farmers used
to communicate with one another before
they had modern conveniences like
electricity or telephone haulers had a
certain rhythm and a modulation that
would create an echo that would travel
over a long distance but there isn't
just one type of holler
there are actually four types of hollers
number one functional it serves a
purpose such as calling down to a field
or calling up from a field when you
needed something number two
communicative you're communicating a
message such as good morning good
evening number three distress you need
help
number four expressive just for sheer
fun many times that could be in the form
of tunes or Diddy's these types of
hollers were what the judges were
looking for at the National hollering
contest the first ever national
hollering contest was in 1969 it was
started to raise funds for the local
fire department it became a nationwide
hit hey that's me I won the junior
division in 1978 my heart was a distress
holler it sounded like a siren
everybody had their own twist it they
put on the national Hollerin contest ran
for about 48 years till 2015 we created
the worldwide hollering festival that's
located in hope meals to try to preserve
and keep the tradition of hollering in
life Hollerin is an important piece of
culture in this region because it helps
us remember our past we can also
appreciate the modern conveniences we
have today Hollerin is part of simpler
times and it's just something that we
need to treasure because we need to know
our history
I love hollering because it brings the
community together in just the
fellowship that you have with one
another we want to keep that tradition
alive
[Music]
go ahead put in your mouth go since the
first time it was announced to the
public that we are growing these there
are literally thousands of YouTube
videos of people eating Carolina Reapers
all over the world but I get a kick out
of most of them though it can be
unpleasant it's not a dangerous thing to
eat super hot peppers it's a chemical
reaction your brain perceives as heat so
you will stop doing it
[Music]
I'm smoking at curry I created the
Carolina Reaper I got into breeding
peppers in college Minh just really was
interested in getting hotter and hotter
peppers once I tried them Guiness
awarded me the world record for the
hottest pepper in November of 2013 to
breed these things I crossed a ghost
pepper with a habanero and what came out
was this evil looking pepper it had
warts all over blisters they call them
and the first time I tasted it it
knocked me to my knees we get our
peppers tested regularly at Winthrop
University by dr. Calaway in the
chemistry lab all peppers are measured
by Scoville heat units which tell you
how hot the pepper is bell peppers have
zero Scoville heat units Tala Pino is
about five thousand a serrano 20,000 red
habaneros 200,000 ghost peppers 600,000
then you get to the Carolina Reaper
which is one point five six nine million
Scoville heat units the hottest thing in
the world when you eat the Carolina
Reaper the first sensation you get is
sweet and then all sudden the heat
starts going it's like burning burning
burning then the physiological stuff
starts your eyes will bloodshot they
just start tearing up and watering the
skin flushes you start breathing hard
your metabolism starts raising up some
people say it's like eating molten lava
others will say it's like licking the
Sun to me it's like eating a charcoal
briquette and no matter what you do you
cannot get that burn out of the back of
your mouth I mean it's crazy a lot of
what I do is creative expression you
will look for traits in one pepper and
you look for traits in another and you
try to combine them and keep both those
traits there are other breeders who are
trying to break our record but we've
been holding unreleased peppers in our
back pocket that are twice as hot or
more than the Carolina Reaper that we
could submit to Guinness at any time
my perception of what the limits are of
how hot you can greet a pepper has
changed as the science has progressed
over the years just tell me something
can't be done I'm gonna figure out a way
to do it people enjoy it ma'am
especially when it happens to other
people this definitely a factor of
schadenfreude watching something go
terribly wrong to someone else
[Music]
your new u-haul
you're about to start your first
semester at Duke and driving down the
road you see this sign and another sign
you paid no attention and then this sign
lights up and then disaster strikes
you're about to get your 15 minutes of
fame all thanks to this man
hi I'm uragan hen these infamous these
parts right you're gonna one could say
that yes
oh yeah no no see eleven foot eight guy
around here you're getting this wife
started eleven foot eight calm which is
what exactly
eleven foot eight website records all
the truck crashes that happen here at
the eleven foot eight bridge it's really
all it is eight years ago I set up
camera outside my office here and
started recording the traffic that goes
under the railroad trestle behind me
within a few weeks I recorded a truck
crashing into the railroad bridge since
installing the camera Jurgen has
uploaded a video of a hundred and
thirteen crashes at the bridge and
amassed over ten million views most
bridges in the state have a 15-foot
clearance the 11 foot a bridge however
has built a hundred years ago hence
lower height and now thanks to your
gonna these crashes the dedicated
following our fans are really intensely
interested in these crashes and they
love to buy souvenirs old piece of crash
art what's crasher the crash art are
bent mangled pieces of aluminum that
usually form the frame of the truck and
the impact crushes that aluminum
and kind of twists it in interesting
shapes people will buy the crash art
they love it for some of them it's
almost like owning a piece of the Berlin
Wall
when isn't the town just raise the
trestle or lower the rope from the
perspective of the city and the state do
T the low clearance is clearly marked
and it's up to the driver to decide
their next move
structural change is that this
intersection would be extremely costly
well at least we have these awesome
videos right I get no satisfaction out
of seeing a new crash if we found an
actual solution to prevent this tomorrow
I'd be all over it I love it
[Music]
[Music]